[Music]
[Applause]
Daniel Jeremiah NFL network analyst and
he's out at the Combine NFL Network the
scouting combine kicks off today at
three Eastern on NFL Network where they
look at defensive linemen and
linebackers Segway to Jalen Carter since
he's not there any longer Daniel what
kind of questions uh left the building
when Jalen Carter left
well I think there's a lot to be uh to
be answered I just I did see something
online a few minutes ago Dan where it
said that he was headed on his way back
here to meet with teams
um so I don't know if that's if that's
an accurate report or not but I did see
that floating around on the internet but
uh you know this is uh just an awful
it's an awful situation it's a tragedy
obviously with what resulted there and
it's a very serious very serious since
being taken very serious by teams you
know the one thing is uh there's time
here between now and the draft and if
you're going to draft Jalen Carter
you're going to be spending a lot of
time with him between now and then and
you're going to be doing a lot of of
digging to see you know what what else
is there because this is uh troubling
would be a gross understatement and we
always it's a sliding scale of how much
baggage and how good you are Jalen
Carter by all accounts is a top five
pick maybe number one overall would you
uh where do you have him in your mock
draft
yeah he's my number one player in the
whole draft Dan
um I think he's the best football player
in the country so
um you know he's As Good As It Gets in
this year and he plays a position where
if you know you talk about scarcity it's
hard to find interior guys with his with
his ability you know there's a lot of
really talented Edge rushers that come
uh into the league each and every year
uh the number of dominant defensive
tackles that can really mess things up
from a run and pass standpoint those
guys are hard to find he's a rare rare
rare Talent how would you assess the
quarterback draft if you were going to
grade it to or compare it to previous
drafts
you know the slam dunk Guy where we've
had years I mean Joe burrow from start
to finish I felt real comfortable that
he was going to be a really good player
he was the best one
um Trevor Lawrence the same way we saw
that years coming and he was just they
were clean you know they checked every
box in terms of the size and the skill
set and everything you need from the
position I think these guys this year I
think they're really gifted I think
they're really talented I would say
there's five of them I think will end up
being starting quarterbacks which is a
huge number in draft so from that
standpoint it's really good but they're
all you know they all come with a
varying level of risk and it's whatever
risk you're comfortable taking it's
different with each of them if Caleb
Williams was available in this draft
what would the Chicago Bears do with the
number one pick
well I you know I've seen enough of him
I haven't done you know the uh the big
work up on him but I've seen enough to
know that when guys like that come into
the draft you take them and you uh and
you move on from whoever else is in the
building okay yeah because I don't know
about Bryce young and I did have an NFL
scout to say that he wasn't all in on
Justin fields to begin with and if you
have somebody you truly love then take
them because you reset that quarterback
clock if you ran the Bears knowing these
prospects what would you do with the
with the number one overall pick
yeah I'm going to take you on a Winding
Road here because the the first part of
that question is who do you like better
do you like Justin Fields better or do
you like Bryce young personally I have a
higher grade on Bryce young and so then
the follow-up question is well then
great you ought to take Bryce young and
you should trade Justin Fields but to me
I think the underrated aspect of the
evaluation of quarterbacks Dan is the
fit and I just don't like the fit of
Bryce young in Chicago I just don't
think it works I I can make a strong
case for him explain that to me though
Daniel the the fit as far as weather uh
style I mean what goes into this
so yeah look I scouted for a couple
teams in the AFC North okay and when we
were looking at quarterbacks we wanted
bigger guys more physical guys if you go
back at that time you had Ben
Roethlisberger and Carson Palmer in the
division
um you know the Ravens end up ultimately
getting Joe Flacco but the the feeling
was you know you're playing in a
physical division you're playing outdoor
and weather and wind and all the
elements it just you wanted a more
physical guy to hold up in there they
play it's a different game when you play
indoors
um and you know I just look at Bryce I
think of you know how everything is
crisp and on time
um get the ball out when you have indoor
field you've got indoor footing timing
is uh it's a lot easier there and I
think all of his strengths play well in
in that environment and that you know in
that AFC South with either Houston or
Indy yeah and you know speaking of which
Justin Fields actually fits the Chicago
Bears style it does you know when he
might I like the cold weather but
um and and I'm curious about CJ Stroud
because
I was watching the uh
the Georgia game and all of a sudden I
go I would show that to every Scout and
just say every team look at this break
down CJ Stroud
yeah that was it's funny you mentioned
that Dan because you know I had kind of
a a grade on him a certain grade on him
I watched him over the summer
um coming into the season and I liked
him but you know gosh I just wish there
was a little more suddenness or urgency
or like a play-making aspect to his game
he's I think he's just a pure thrower I
mean it is it is uh fun to watch the
ball come off his hand
um he can he can make every type of
throw but you know free rusher you could
unblock guy I wanted to see him you know
create and make some plays and uh in
basketball I guess the analogy would be
he was more of a shooter than a score
you know and he just didn't really have
that element so then I'm watching
throughout the season and I'm like okay
I think his arm's gotten a little bit
stronger so I like that but not enough
to move him up off of my grade that I
already have and he watched him
throughout the whole year and I'm like
okay this is kind of a DNA match he's
the same guy he's not changing I know
exactly what he is and then I turn on
the semi-final game and I go wait wait
wait a second who's this I know and
that's the old that's the old scouting
Dan it's like if you can do it once you
can do it so you know what's in there so
one of the things I'd be curious yeah
I'm curious to see how healthy he was
during the year
um and then maybe it was just as simple
as when you're Ohio State you don't play
many teams that can put you in positions
to have to do that well Georgia can
Georgia can make you move around a
little bit
um so I moved him up I moved him up
after that game because I know it's in
there are you more interested concerned
about Bryce Young's height or his weight
yeah I would say the frame you know just
the frame just being a narrow frame
lighter you know the height I think he
had two or three bolts tipped that you
know that doesn't show up as an issue
there's times where maybe a couple times
on tape I can say okay I don't think he
saw this guy but when you have a strong
enough arm and he does you know it's not
a you know he doesn't have a Matthew
Stafford type arm not of a homes type
arm but it's plenty good enough when you
when you're a little undersized one of
the things they've been able to do and I
think it started really uh with Russell
Wilson
um as they get so much depth in their
drop so that you can just create
distance between you and the line of
scrimmage helps you see you know Drew
Drew Brees always had that awesome
interior you know the center and the two
guards were always really good you
invested in those guys and uh and they
kept that that space and that distance
for him to be able to see so
um I I think I think he can navigate
around that one of the interesting
things I was talking to a team the other
day and I hadn't thought of this part of
it and he said so every if you love
Bryce young but your question is the
durability he said well then why don't
you go and that's maybe a little bit
more than you'd like to in the backup
quarterback knowing that he's probably
going to have to play two or three games
a year you know and and I don't want to
hear that
but but Dan that's a way where you kind
of get your cake and eat it too you know
if you can get if you're getting 14
games of high high level quarterback
play and you've got to yeah you got to
give them a week here there in a 17 Game
season I'd rather have that than to than
sacrifice the talent of the position and
roll somebody out there is not as good
for 17 weeks talking to Daniel Jeremiah
former NFL scout and uh he's an analyst
for the NFL Network scouting combine
kicks off today at three Eastern on NFL
Network well if that's the case then I
would I use that same blueprint for
Kyler Murray would I use it for Lamar
Jackson these yeah quarterbacks who are
not going to make it through 17 games uh
they're going to be nicked fields in
there yeah put fields in there as well
if you're going to rely on these guys
you know it's two different things one
of them is the size factor and the other
one is guys that really like to use
their legs and and be a part of it so uh
if those two cases show up I think there
is wisdom in investing in that in that
backup quarterback if you ran the C
Seahawks what would you do with that
fifth overall pick
it's a great that's a great call you
know they have been doing a lot of work
on quarterbacks I know you know that I'm
sure they don't want to get Geno done
um but I think even if they do get Geno
done I don't think that would preclude
them from taking one
um you know thinking they could get the
guy of the future I would say if you
have a quarterback that you love in this
draft if you're the Seahawks I wouldn't
let the fact that you've got a guy
coming off of a pro bowl season at Geno
Smith to turn you from taking one
um but you know the way he played last
year the way you know they've got some
some pretty good young pieces on this
team I I know usually when you have a
defensive minded head coach and they
watch a crappy defense all season long
Dan
um that's that's you get on a one-track
mind there and say I just can't stomach
watching uh front seven like this
anymore I've got to get some difference
makers would you take a running back in
the top ten
the only team I would do it for is the
team that has a less than zero percent
chance of doing it and that's the
Philadelphia Eagles
um just because their rosters in such
great shape you know I I I you know it's
you're never gonna take a running back
over a pass rusher if you don't have
pass rushers you're never going to take
one over a quarterback a left tackle
like they have all those key positions
filled
um and you know you can add depth
obviously fortify them but I just think
with their roster as close as they were
to winning a Super Bowl and then you
take Bijan Robinson who's is talented
back as we've seen in a long time is
right up there with all those top guys
that have gone up there in the previous
generation when we used to care about
running backs I I think you put him in
that offense with hurts with those two
receivers with Goddard and all of a
sudden you throw Bijan Robinson in there
that might be the piece to push you over
the top that being said I work there I
know Holly Roseman really well and it'll
never happen
I would think buffalo buffalo would be
the team that if I don't think they can
get him but Buffalo having him oh he'd
be a home run yeah
um I'll be a home run he's a great
player I'll Circle back to uh what the
original topic uh would you draft Jalen
Carter hi
I would want to know a lot more
information before I would be
comfortable doing that as great as as
great as he is Dan
um you know I know that you're not going
to have everybody that has a a perfectly
clean sheet in terms of of their
background that's not realistic and guys
make mistakes and you know remember
these guys are young but this is not
this is not a uh this is not a small
ordeal this resulted in the loss of life
and and that would be uh that would be
very difficult for me personally always
great to talk to you have fun out there
we appreciate your time Daniel
thank you Dan appreciate you that's uh
Daniel Jeremiah NFL Network and former
NFL scout for uh two teams Eagles and
the Ravens